today I'm going to be speaking with
James underdown who's executive director
for the center for inquiry West in Los
Angeles and the chair and founder of the
center for inquiry investigations group
he's also the host of the upcoming web
series skepta lab the bunk stops here
James really great to have you on I
appreciate it yeah my pleasure thanks
for having me on so one of the things
that your organization has done is you
have offered money five hundred thousand
dollars
for definitive proof of superpowers or
of a supernatural ability
um and the money continues to be
available it's never it's never been
collected on so let's first to
understand what are the parameters of
the offer
well yeah the offer is
for anyone
prove paranormal
scientific test conditions and that
means that you can't just call us up and
say
you shot a video of something weird
happening send me a check or just take
it on their word alone you have to be
able to show up show us in person and
control conditions mean that we're going
to make sure to the best of our ability
that you're not cheating or using some
ulterior means to achieve whatever
effect you're talking about okay how
many let's go through the funnel how
many people have gone through the proper
process of applying
well
average
four years ago we had over
50 application
we average between one and two hundred
applications a year and usually it does
Whittle down when people find out what
they're going to have to do
I think it self-eliminates the people
who are planning to cheat okay
um so and in fact
as long as I'm on that subject no one
has ever tried to cheat during a test
anyone who shows up
actually believes that they have these
superpowers
so um but the but it goes from so it
goes from 100 to 200 a year applying and
we only test like probably half a dozen
by the time all is said and done and
everybody understands each other the
negotiations we figure out what the test
is going to be what they say they can do
what we're comfortable with and uh then
We're Off to the Races so the fact that
people don't try to cheat suggests that
these are true believers they genuinely
believe they have whatever power they
claim to have
absolutely so far 100 percentage of 100
percent of them now of course we do plan
for people cheating so we we treat
everyone as if you know you know we
close off these Avenues of cheating but
yeah everyone who shows up thinks
they're gonna succeed and a lot of them
are really sort of surprised that you
know they can't
defy Millions to one odds in in their
telepathic ability okay so let's talk
about that when they fail
give us a sense of some of the reactions
do do does anybody say hey you know what
I actually can't do this thing or do
people blame the test conditions do they
say it was an off day
yeah there's I mean I I keep saying I'm
gonna start this the big book of excuses
yeah a lot of them say you know too much
skeptic energy in the room right
some of them say oh this test wasn't
fair even though they agreed to it you
know five minutes earlier
some of them it takes a few days for
them to to say that they were cheated or
somehow wronged
um you know so it varies there and let's
see so we've been testing people at this
point for 23 years
and there are probably been two or three
who have come back and said you know
maybe I need to rethink this a little
bit and reconsider what's going on
what sorts of claims have you tested are
there types that are the most common
ones
yeah probably the most common test we do
is telepathy so this is people thinking
that they can
project their thoughts into someone
else's mind that's most common some
people think that they can receive
thoughts lately we've been getting a lot
of people who they say they can
telekinesis is a big one so the ability
to move something with your mind without
touching it physically or anything so a
lot of people have been sending in
claims about moving clouds or doing
things to the sky
um
Dowsers we've tested a couple of Dowsers
uh some healers it's it's really all
over the map some people I mean we've
had people say that they could create a
rainstorm in the middle of a desert
um so like for that one do you go out to
the middle of the desert
well what we in these sort of predictive
sort of
claims
we make it very clear that look you know
this can't be in the Amazon jungle it
can't be on an island in Hawaii it's got
to be somewhere that doesn't have rain
very often you have to predict the exact
time
in the exact place that this is going to
happen so we close these windows down so
it's not just a chance occurrence of
something that would happen anyway right
um how do you deal with I mean I'm
guessing although you can tell me if my
assumption is wrong that sometimes
people who are struggling with mental
health issues come to you and say I can
do this that or the other thing how how
does that happen how do you deal with
that it actually happens fairly commonly
especially with the telepaths so if
you're experiencing voices in your head
you're seeing some hallucination or
you're convinced that everyone can hear
your thoughts or that uh you know you
can hear their thoughts those are
symptoms from the DSM the diagnostical
statistical manual from the mental
health world yeah those are known
conditions and symptoms
so you know we we try to gently suggest
to people
um what you're experiencing is
consistent with some forms of mental
illness please consider that that may be
what's going on here we'll test you
anyway yeah but um know that this is you
know probably what's happening and by
the way
this isn't just me some blame in saying
this we have three psychologists on our
team and a psychiatrist so they're all
in full agreement that these are common
symptoms that people suffering from
mental illness sometimes uh experience
when people
um come in there are there are instances
of this sort of thing where the people
who assert these abilities will say that
they are by their nature not really
testable in this way now of course the
problem for organizations like yours is
that well then then we're dealing in an
unfalsifiable type of claim it's I'm
asserting this and it's not even the
type of claim you can evaluate do you
what do you get some of those and then
are you just not able to move forward in
that case yeah so it could be so some
people say that you know uh this just
happens every once in a while and I
can't put my finger on it I say when we
say say look we're not going to follow
you around 24 hours a day right you have
to be able to do this sort of on demand
so
um yeah it's just uh by the nature of it
um we're not going to fly to you in
Istanbul and you know spend six weeks
with you until this crops up again so
and by the way we do we test people from
all over the world just the other day we
tested a guy who was in Spain
who said he could hypnotize us into
making
us roll our eyes up into our head you
know like you're going into a coma or
something yeah so some of these things
can be tested via Zoom or Skype or
whatever and uh we're willing to do that
if it if the test lends itself to that
that's convenient so you don't have to
necessarily fly around to then have your
eyes not roll up into the back of your
head
yeah that could be dangerous if you're
on the road
um so the new show skeptilab the bunk
stops here it debuts in just a couple of
days I believe with three episodes on
telekinesis astrology and telepathy yeah
we're we're we started shooting this web
series you know we've been doing this my
group the center for acquirer
investigations group has been doing this
for 23 years now since 2000 and you know
we just decided to we have these
scads of experiences with these people
and the benefit of Decades of
information from uh the committee for
skeptical inquiry uh skeptical Inquirer
magazine all these people that we work
with and are a part of
we thought why not try to get some of
this debunking information out there
uh we actually got a little bit of a
grant to help us out with getting it
produced
and I know some people here in Hollywood
uh who are mostly on our side in terms
of getting Science Education out to the
public so you know we got some of these
celebrities to help out and they're
funny and so we get the information out
there with a little bit of humor and
then bring in some experts too to add to
the mix and and really try to convince
people that the stuff isn't what it
seems to be yeah I love this stuff so
I'm really looking forward to it
astrology in particular is interesting
because with a lot of that that's about
personality traits and vague horoscopes
and these kind of Barnum type statements
what how do you debunk that
yes some of the things are are a little
tricky astrology was kind of fun we had
the help of Julia Sweeney who was a star
on Saturday Night Live a while back
and one of the things we did was we went
out to Hollywood Boulevard and set up a
table and said free astrology readings
and we put all the star signs and little
bins in front and people came up and got
there reading and read it on camera then
they scored the reading and said you
know how well did we did it do on
describing you the Libra that it
pretends to describe and they're giving
it nines and tens out of ten and then
we'd say okay now pick up an Aries and
it's the exact same
astrology reading star reading
so what does that tell you and a lot of
them admitted right on the spot you know
that you could write something that
applies to just about everybody and it
really isn't predictive at all it's just
a general statement well written toward
that end yeah and what's interesting
about that is in some sense you could
say that doesn't really debunk it
because if you just write a statement
that applies to most people everybody
would accept it I guess there would be
an another way to test it which would be
with different statements and and kind
of like
randomizing them and controlling you
know you could do a more complex test
too I'm sure right right you could you
could set up you could get 12 people
together and say okay talk to them a
little bit and pick out which one is the
Sagittarius right you know based on your
discussion but we added one other thing
to this discussion and and this is what
we try to do on skepta lab is we got
Phil play two is a working astronomer
and we said you know look talk about
these these constellations out there
which are meant to be the driving force
behind astrology talk about you know the
influence the physical influence they
have on Earth and Phil went and and
talked about how far they are the fact
that just because it might look like a
crab up in the sky doesn't mean these
stars are anywhere near each other
they're not the same distance or
anything
um he talked about the gravitational
pull of you know like a boss going by
you as as a bigger gravitational pull
than you know some star light years away
so there's a lot of other there's
multiple ways to think of why astrology
is is not real do you get into not so
much
um
more in the direction of some of the
medical stuff like for example you know
acupuncture is one that's been looked at
extensively and it seems as though in
most tests so-called sham acupuncture
works as well as quote real acupuncture
the idea being that the process of
having someone listen to your symptoms
and then maybe the Endorphin release
from the from the needles no matter
where you place them does have an effect
but it's no different with real version
do you get into that stuff at all
uh we do
um you know we're not my group isn't
involved in that sort of research per se
but yeah you're right I mean there are
aspects of a lot of the faith healing
kind of stuff and the alternative
medicine sort of stuff that is you know
the power suggestion the placebo effect
have a great deal to do with people
feeling better now we do test healers
and in fact
um just a month or two ago we had a guy
come in to test for the half million
dollars who said he could heal a lipoma
on one of our guys neck it had a little
lipoma on there so we measured it and we
got all these cameras you know watching
it as he's as he's doing it and he
couldn't do it so you know if you can if
your claim is that you can heal it on
the spot and have visual
incontrovertible evidence right now that
it's healed that's fine but you know you
get these you get like Benny Hinn and
these televangelist healers who say
they're making
uh they're healing people and we just
punch a lot of holes and why that's not
really happening what happens to all the
video footage of these failed tests
um you know we're getting better at
since we got the cameras for skepta lab
we're trying to get a little bit better
we are we do shoot a lot most of this
stuff
um but I don't know how to edit or
anything so it's sort of being stored
right now and we're using some of it for
the skepta lab okay and we'll use it in
the future as well I hope it's it's
fascinating stuff so if there's someone
in the audience there is a 500 000
reward available to you and you can find
out more by looking into the center for
inquiry we've been speaking with James
underdown the upcoming web series
debuting in just a couple days is
skeptilab the bunk stops here James
really appreciate your time today
thanks for having me on David it's been
a pleasure